foreign
Baton Rouge hey Matt how are you
I'm doing well sir thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
I just have a quick question so I'm a
relatively new listener and I started
listening just in time to hear you talk
about the bank craziness going on and
I'm just curious this might be a really
stupid question but how can the FDIC
ensure every deposit under 250
000 where do they get the money in I'm
not even exactly sure what the FDIC is
you get like a brief crash course
rundown sure it stands for Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation
it's the federal government
writing insurance
against your bank's failure
now do they have a pile of money equal
to everyone's covered amount absolutely
not but your insurance company does not
have a pile of money equal to everyone
at State Farm totaling their car this
week either
if everybody totaled their car at once
State Farm's gone
they don't have that much money okay
what they're running is they're running
probabilities statistical probability of
this occurring and so if enough Banks
went down at one time to destroy the
amount of money that the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation the
federal government could get their hands
on uh that means the entire American
economy has collapsed and you should buy
a gun
gotcha gotcha so it's it's publicly
funded no well it Matt think of it like
how how your insurance works if you have
State Farm everybody's paying their
premium and they're paying into this big
pile of money so that when somebody
needs to actually use their insurance
there's money there and it's the same
thing with FDIC these insured banks are
paying premiums to FDIC okay so there's
a big stack of money the banks fund the
FDIC with their premiums but they don't
give it enough money to cover all bank
failures that simultaneously occurring
no
gotcha but it is a lot of money it's
plenty to cover anything that's actually
going to occur yeah but if uh but but
the mathematics are to your point Matt
uh the mathematics are just like if all
of State Farm Autos had a got totaled in
one month they would there's not enough
they don't have the money to cover all
that because they're running it on
probabilities and so this is an
insurance policy based on a you know a a
projected number of bank failures in a
given decade and plus a lot and so it's
a very conservative set of mathematics
meaning you could have a whole bunch of
banks fail we had a lot of them cashed
out FDIC and and went Belly Up fdsc took
them over resold the banks the sale of
the bank the money goes back into the
insurance policy as well to cover but um
that happened in 2008 a lot more than in
the last in the last three or four
months or so so but if you had um
twenty five thousand Banks crash at one
time there's not enough money and by the
way if twenty five thousand Banks crash
at one time we got issues Life as We
Know It in America no longer exists
that's right there's a whole lot of
other crap that goes with that that
can't be just an independent thing yeah
you got to understand that if that
occurs everywhere you shop is out of
business oh yeah we're looking for clean
water and in in supplies yeah yeah we're
not we're not looking for gold
yeah that's exactly what we're doing so
that that but it's a good question it's
good something to think about so
um yeah and it's good that you know we
do a little bit of educational
occasionally